[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun
very excited to be talking about a topic
that we just did a live event on we just
did a live event on social media and the
attention economy the neuroscience of
well-being the future of mental health
and now our guest who was on the panel
that evening is joining us for a
one-on-one conversation I'm very excited
to have dr. Joseph Villegas joining us
thank you for coming out to the show my
pleasure really appreciate it very
excited to be talking to you in depth
one-on-one about all of this and your
background has led you to a very cool
place now being nested in this craziness
of civilization figuring out how to use
technology and how it affects our brains
and so yeah you did lots of work you did
a PhD in psychology alright and that was
at university of wisconsin-madison and
Center for healthy minds as well the
graduate work mm-hmm there yep and that
was also at in Wisconsin that was eight
and a half years that's oh that's a long
time yeah so I did I was in doing
graduate training for seven years I was
did my clinical internship for another
year that's like a year like full time
training in psychotherapy and
and treatment and assessment and so then
yeah so then you put that all together
to eight years it's a long time a long
time to learn how to do science learn
how to do treatment and mental health
working that's all settings you got to
have patience and it's been a long
evolution you're teaching us about this
about how it went
you know from sitting here on you have
two couches the listening to what
somebody had to say about their state of
life you now where we have digital
therapists digital doctors doctors this
is nuts balls and segues how much even
since the time I started school just how
much the field has changed already and
is gonna continue to changing which i
think is maybe their the real
interesting thing to be thinking about
looking at in towards yeah and that's
crazy that you say that because that's
you know that's only just for you
starting so and then we're not even
talking about the kids that are starting
now
right and okay but before we get to the
awesomeness of the today's times let's
go to child Joe how did how did child
Joe pick up neuroscience psychology
behavioral sciences like how did you get
being meditation you know to make a long
story short I it's it's interesting I
didn't start out immediately I might as
you interested in psychology or well
definitely enough I I'm actually the
first the first kind of things I was
interested more Natural Sciences so
astronomy physics I love doing math as a
kid and and I was really interesting
like cosmology like these big questions
about you know where does it all come
from which you probably relate to yeah
and so I I just would read about I would
read books by Isaac Asimov and coughs
say again and those kind of things and
then but there's one thing that's left
out of that that whole picture which is
an amazingly beautiful picture an
incredible accomplishment of human
civilization right all these models of
physics are missing the mind yeah right
it creeps in like in quantum in quantum
mechanics
systems behave differently whether
they've been observed or not right and
so that implies an observer and there's
something interesting there right
there's some hint of it but it's not
really it's kind of missing right and so
so pretty much at a certain age I
started getting interested you know kind
of in high school when a lot of kids get
philosophical I guess you know I started
thinking about this and getting really
curious about it and it seemed to me
really like the the one piece that
really wasn't wasn't well understood too
the more I started reading about it I
thought well compared to how well we
seem to understand electromagnetism we
have no idea what's going on with our
minds and then simultaneously I was also
getting the age where I was beginning
awareness of just the state of the world
I guess you can say and and even just
what I saw around me and starting to
realize that materially we can have
everything every possible material need
fulfilled certainly you know I was lucky
enough to grow up in a pretty nice area
where you know people had more than
enough materially and yet I saw all
kinds of unhappiness and misery around
me and so that really impressed on me
that the answer you know the answer to
human happiness is not going to be a
smaller transistor you know like going
down to five nanometer transistors or
something that's not going to get us out
of the mess we're in in a certain way
and if you look at most of the big
problems when I started thinking about
it most of the big problems on the
planet right now come down to human
behavior and human psychology you know
and so if we're gonna solve any of those
problems we have to make some kind of
headway there and simultaneously we had
mill you know barely any idea how our
minds work and then and then if you fast
forward a few years you know we also
have the neuroscience piece come in I
wasn't a young at ourselves objectively
in the mirror oh yeah I mean we ya know
none of us want we don't want to do that
you know we're not built to do it
honestly we're not they were not
designed for that actually it's so we're
like going against the grain when we try
to take it on as look at ourselves
so I didn't even get involved in like as
we as you know like I I didn't I worked
in tech for a while I didn't actually
get involved in research for quite a
while you were doing software
development for like eight years
yeah I worked for climate science I was
like science so I worked for climate
research center I worked I did like some
like auto college I worked on like some
just engineering for like like sonar
systems all kinds of stuff and then I
also was interested in what it was like
to work in the private sector so I
worked for a company called amplify now
and in New York and they do educational
technology so I like the mission it
seemed like a positive mission and a
great group of people so I got a little
bit of an idea of what it was like to do
you know to be in that you know in this
startup world that we're surrounded by
here yeah and I was really interested in
I was almost considered staying there
but I really really wanted to be working
with human behavior and psychology and
at 10 years ago it was hard to find a
way to do that which is really funny now
because it's like you know that's all
we're talking I can we talk about right
there's all the social and psychological
aspects of all this technology but it's
like 2008 it was a different world all
right so I went into graduate school to
do my PhD do clinical psychology because
clinical psychology is about changing
behavior and it's about well-being like
that's that's the more of what we do and
the mission of the field is especially
using using behavior using reflection
and insight and things like that not
necessarily so much of a focus on drugs
or so those kind of things right but
really how can we actually work with our
own minds to to make them healthier and
how does the person that and that
desires a better wife a better
well-being how do they gain insight of
themselves there's maybe someone else
that can help them find that insight and
then act on it right and then put that
insight into practice so you actually a
see change in your life
right that's and so that is what
clinical psychologists specialize in and
and then simultaneously being a techie
and being a geek like I just inevitably
fell into the neuroscience side of
things because there's this whole
explosion going on in studying the brain
and it really brings together the
physical side of things the natural
science side of things with kind of the
questions these kind of really heady
questions of consciousness and mind and
philosophy and those kind of things yeah
you're totally in this put this group of
of thinkers that go to this cosmic
perspective and then they understand oh
my god but we know nothing about our own
minds mhm and then you went super you
know inward to neuroscience and
psychology and so I loved that group
that group those types of thinkers think
because they get the they get the the
most the craziest thing which is
consciousness and then they also get the
insanity of the vastness of the cosmos
and the big picture and the small
picture microcosms so I really like how
you you know placed yourself there so
can you tell us about your your
dissertation and you know that was that
in meditation yep yeah please so so the
Center for healthy minds is is a center
that focuses on on cultivating
well-being psychological well-being and
that has taken a number of forms one of
the specialties is the neuroscience of
emotion so that's been a big focus of my
graduate training in my research
understanding what is the neural basis
of emotion and what are the what's the
neural basis of emotion regulation and
how do how do we take advantage of those
mechanisms train them how do we take
advantage of neuroplasticity the ability
of our brain to change and rewire itself
over the course of our lives to really
bring ourselves to a state of better
well-being psychologically and a big
piece of that has been mindfulness
meditation research so part of what our
Center is really well known for is a lot
of groundbreaking studies that really
opened the way for rigorous scientific
research on mindfulness meditation so
starting with studies of Tibetan monks
which you know probably you might have
seemed like magazine covers and things
like that from you know like the
mid-2000s of that stuff right so we had
two bettin monks coming through the lab
really don't yell out and then we were
talking about this too beforehand about
the
how funny it is that this has been
around thousands of years and now we're
bringing the monks into the depth to get
the hard scientific evidence that yeah
oh look at how official it is so an
interesting that's going both ways you
know because there are exchange
programmes where the monks are coming to
the west to learn about biology
chemistry and physics right they have
the equivalent of like a PhD in you know
in the very very rich philosophy and
psychology of Buddhism and yet like
their training and all some areas where
we're really advanced here is totally a
I and my I molecular right and and of
those kind of things to even more so
right so so there's a kind of a I think
what's happening maybe you could say all
over the world right now is this
exchange of information we're at
different cultures different groups of
people have expertise the West really
needs mindfulness and we have the
ability and there's I mean you can just
see by the uptake right how populous has
gotten when I started meditating which
was in high school in the 1990s like
people looked at me like as an alien
like when I talked about meditation or
like a cult like I was in the heart
Krishna's or something especially where
I grew up which was suburban outside DC
suburban Maryland like nobody was
meditating it was not a thing it was
like it was really weird it was or it
was like a thing from the 60s like you
had your hippie you know yeah like your
happy person who like they kind of moved
out to the woods and they never came
back you know that kind of thing so the
attitude was like so different and you
have a friend that you could talk to
about it I had like really like my one
best friend and I got interested in this
together and and it was like literally
just us and the funny thing is like we
literally we looked up then in the phone
book like in the yellow the old one
yellow pages and that's the how I went
to my first meditation center oh my god
like there is no Google yeah and then
we're like you know we went to this tiny
little place handful of people it was
like so under the radar
yeah so but you right there's this
hunger for it and it's been amazing to
me to just watch it completely exploded
load yeah since then
yeah and now like I can't you know I
can't turn around without seeing
mindfulness somewhere like we're and
even even in the settings I'm going into
a these very kind of almost square
you know hospitals even like the VA
hospitals where saying I do training
right like they are putting there's
there's mindfulness training
mindfulness-based therapies or like
everywhere now and it's it's really
infusing things and with an amazing pace
you had a you had actually you were
going to teach us about some of the what
you were doing in your in your
dissertation well right we got and and I
actually have some of the some of the
you know intensive meditation practices
linked to slower respiration right right
you know and then also I just want to
just quickly bring up how this was so
cool we'll get to this more in depth but
this is so interesting how it all starts
with me now in the middle is like this
new idea yeah yeah yeah yeah so we just
mentioned we were just talking about
this is from the Department of Veteran
Affairs website yep and I do I like I I
have done this work with veterans where
I'm actually but since I'm talking about
this I need to be super clear I'm not
representing the views of the Department
of Veteran Affairs in our talk right
that's just a disclaimer right you don't
have to make but but in my personal like
in my work there I've had this
incredible pleasure like teaching I'm
teaching mindfulness meditation I mean
these are like military veterans these
guys have been over in Iraq and
Afghanistan Vietnam vets yeah like this
is these are not you know hippie too you
know like these are not will hippie
new-age type guys and but the VA is
brought into this and and then working
with them and there and they they get an
amazing
out of these practices and so it's like
incredible for me to see this thing that
you know that I was doing and like
feeling like I was way out on the
fringes with now kind of be so
thoroughly thoroughly integrated yeah
and you can you know we'll get them more
yes and how this fits into where the
future mental health and where it's all
going so to talk a little bit about my
research I've been interested in
mechanisms since I started graduate
school and that's taken a few different
forms in particular I've been really
interested in the way that mind and body
come together in emotion so one of the
key things about yeah so right so
extended mindfulness training is not
just training one's cognitive processes
but it also clears to be training and
retraining the body as well in ways
we're just beginning to understand so
the interesting thing about emotion
particularly is that it's it's emotion
is so all-encompassing
so any change II people argue endlessly
about definitions of emotion but one of
the ways I think of it is actually as a
coordinated change of state across the
entire body in mind that's oriented
towards a particular goal or a
particular type of response to your
environment so like when you get afraid
it's like you perceive a threat in your
environment something that you probably
can't fight or eliminate and you need to
get away from and protect yourself from
and every single part of your body and
every single part of your brain is
involved in that fear response so your
heart rate change is your circulation
changes your muscles activate even your
body posture changes you got to be more
protective then and if we look at brain
activation one of the interesting things
is people will be used to look for like
a fear circuit or an anger circuit in
the brain or a region that would be
associated specifically with and and
every attempt to do that has resulted in
the conclusion that you cannot limit it
to one region of the brain instead what
you get like a big Zilla plays a big
role people yeah so people think of like
oh the amygdala is the fear part of your
brain but that's not true at all that's
a total misconception but it plays a
large role
it is very involved but really because
the more than anything else the amygdala
is like a salience detector it detects
what is important in your environment to
tune in to hmm
and that can be that that you can see
how that's obviously involved in the
process you know over of a fear response
but it's only one little piece and there
so there every part of the brain that
tuning into what's salient when it's a
executive functioning active yeah you
can what it's doing is its signalling
what we call bottom-up yeah yeah
so yeah so the amygdala is kind of
saying hey hey you'd better pay
attention to this
yeah yeah right and then you can say no
no I know you're saying that but
actually I need to be you know I'm
supposed to be writing right now you
know but sometimes you you know you you
your glance moves and then you think oh
oh yeah you know I mean I do need to so
it's kind of like a nudge right and our
emotion emotional responses are designed
to be quick and automatic so sometimes
that emotional response goes along with
that
bottom-up attention it's a physiological
change that's the key is that this is
across your entire brain pretty much
your whole brain is involved in
processing the information and in the
response and then your whole body is
involved at the same time too and there
are feedback loops going back and forth
the immune system is involved your
endocrine system your hormones they're
involved all of it is actually happening
at the same time and by Neutron negated
complex ways yeah I mean by training
when you do mindfulness training
meditation training you're reap a
turning the entirety the endocrine
system we're talking yeah respiratory
system we're talking right the full body
relearning not just as you as we may
have thought oh I'm when I'm afraid I'm
just training to just
with becoming better at when I'm afraid
yeah if we try to work with it all up
here we miss we leave out so much right
and so I was really interested in that
from the start
I'd actually did a little bit of
research on looking at different body
postures and I found that this isn't
something I ever I've ever published but
I but what I found was actually looking
at when people take different fearful
body postures or open body postures it
changes their response to startle which
is something that we look at in our
field a lot as a marker of actually that
amygdala regular regulation of of fear
responding so like when your amygdala is
on high alert then like something like a
loud sound will provoke a big startle
and when it's not then then that same
sound will provoke a smaller response
and we can measure it using electrodes
like that pick up subtle muscle
movements around your eye so I was
actually looking at how when people
change your body posture do we see
basically the amygdala acting it like a
knob that's turning up and down people's
fear response and interestingly what I
found is when you crouch like this it
actually turns that knob down when you
crouch down yeah instead of up like this
might think right well when there's a
threat but only when there's a threat
present
right so when you're responding to your
environment right and then that response
is then feeding back into your brain and
changing how you respond so we've got
all these coordinated systems so the
research on respiration really was about
okay so mindfulness training has all
these effects and I was interested in
how much of it is happening
psychologically how much of it is even
happening physiologically and
interesting mindfulness meditation is
not a relaxation practice it's not about
just picturing yourself on a sunny beach
it's about gaining greater awareness but
then over time with advance practice it
potentially does lead to states of calm
mental calm and so over the long term
you know this is important for our
research cube because people's breathing
affects so many other things we want to
know if when we're looking at say a
heart rate variability which is another
measure of of the emotional state so
your heart rate variability drops when
you're under stress or when you're kind
of having like a fear response or an
adrenaline response when we relax yeah
drops when you're relaxed that a certain
component of it drops so it so it heart
so heart rate kinda is the your heart
rate yeah your heart rate is has a
steady rhythm but then there's small
variations and the beat yes yeah and so
steady you're the rhythm the more stress
you know that that's what I was saying
yeah basically in a sense yeah - right
that there's a kind of variability that
we see and that is my that is controlled
by your nervous system and that is
responsive to whether you're stressed or
relaxed and the greater the variability
that will relax yeah yeah sometimes it's
it's yeah one term is RSA or respiratory
sinus arrhythmia that's a technical term
voice RSA is the easy
yeah yeah so so you'll see the more yeah
yeah yeah sound oh yeah so we look at
that and even when we're doing brain
imaging right when people when people
breathe their stuff
right those different cardiograms the
stuff this is new sort of ways to
measure we've had we've actually had
these measures for a long time to couple
things are changed one is we've had the
can we've had the maybe like say in the
last ten to twenty years we've had
enough computing power and cheap enough
equipment and all that to just be
routinely recorded these data processing
it quickly and efficiently and all those
kind of things and then the thing that's
really interesting that's change is now
you know you can get like a Garmin
expand for running or you can even yeah
right and so these things can actually
track some of these measures just in
real time so that's that's another
interesting frontier I'd like to talk
about yeah but so we want to know how
much you know how much of a
physiological component is there going
on as well along with the psychological
component because we're really thinking
about well-being as something that is a
function of your mind and your body
together yeah so I'm telling you I'm
taking forever to tell you about my
dissertation work but that I then
another way that I've been doing that is
looking at physical pain which you might
not immediately connect with the
neuroscience of emotion what does that
pain seems very physical but actually
all the regions and all the brain
networks that are involved in processing
pain and in your experience of pain are
the same ones that are involved in
processing emotions regulating emotions
and and fundamentally the actually the
experience of pain is a part of it is
the physical signal that comes through
specialized pain fibers I mean you know
that innervate your whole body right but
when they reach your central nervous
system then in order for you to actually
have the experience of pain they
actually need to be processed through
these emotional regions and that's part
of that's what makes pain unpleasant
right otherwise it would just be a
sensation like seeing the color red or
the color
interesting so the the processing of
pain goes through areas of the central
nervous system which are motion the same
key yeah so the insula cingulate cortex
Franklin areas of the prefrontal cortex
so which is you know kind of these where
these a lot of this integration is
happening so the insula is place that
integrates sensory information from all
over your body and especially internal
we call interoceptive information and
then there's an area called the orbital
frontal cortex it's called that because
it's near the orbits of your eyes it's
right kind of in your behind your
forehead here and that is a place where
you kind of assign the values is this
like we need some things in your
environment is this a good thing or it's
a bad thing
yeah I mean if you think about cortex
that is some people call it like the
emotional motor region so it's it's
about deciding choosing responses
assigning responses an ACC ACC anterior
cingulate that's where a lot of our we
can go top-down processing through right
and so yeah so then that's what we call
top-down processing which would mean
directing your attention or modulating
things so you think you know I'm
overacting I should calm down right and
then you how am I gonna calm myself down
that that kind of process that when you
do that you're doing some top-down
regulation right like this thing
happened like somebody cut me off in
traffic all of a sudden I'm feeling
really worked up about it
right that's the bottom-up process and
the top-down process is like you know
what I'm gonna rethink this I'm gonna
reframe it maybe they're in a hurry
maybe their wife's on the way to the
hospital I don't even know there's no
reason for me to get angry I'm gonna get
where I'm going
that's the top-down piece yeah yeah so
then we have you know we have these
prefrontal regions dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex is a region that is
known to be important in executive
executive function and regulating these
responses yeah so all these regions are
key in shaping your response to pain so
what I did was I looked at people in a
mindfulness based stress reduction
course it's like an eight-week training
for
people who are brand new to meditation
and we also had a control intervention
we've talked we're gonna chat a little
bit about the importance of like sorting
out not only wife you know first what
works but also why things work they you
know things don't always work for the
reasons we think they do mm-hm and in
particular the controls yeah yeah if you
study pain we particularly we know about
the power of placebo effects which are
really the power of expectation is
another way to say that if we're looking
at mindfulness intervention is it really
just a matter that everybody is excited
about mindfulness everyone thinks it's
gonna work so of course like when you
think some you could say that about
almost anything right so if I think my
lucky rabbit's arm is gonna you know
make my pain less severe it will it will
because it'll influence that emotional
process right I'm wearing it first I'm
not wearing it oh yeah so we want to
know if if mindfulness meditation
training is doing anything distinctive
or you know or is it really just
indistinguishable from the placebo or
from a control intervention that has all
the other scary components of MBSR but
without the without the mindfulness
training and there's a reason why places
like the VAR embody this as a central
theme for helping with mental health and
well-being because it can works mm-hmm
right it works and marieee search now on
mindfulness meditation and mindfulness
based interventions that really
establishes that it is helpful for a
wide variety of condition not every
health condition by any means but for
certain kinds of conditions so we
getting into your present yeah yeah yeah
yeah so maybe before we get into that
then I'll just say you know with with
pain that stay with pain for a second
what I did was I looked at neural
biomarkers that have been developed
using machine learning techniques to
really track at a neural level the
subjective experience of pain
bio-markers there there like you could
think of them as like a map of
activation across the whole brain that
is a particular pattern it's kind of
like like it's it's like a kind of a
lock and key thing like it's designed to
fit a particular pattern of activation
across multiple regions and circuits
that will only it'll only match up it'll
only line up when somebody's
experiencing pain when people are
experiencing other things that might be
unpleasant like I don't know like social
rejection or you know disappointment or
something like that maybe a distinct
event then yeah though the same regions
might be evolved but the pattern won't
line operator okay so you want so you
won't see a response in this biomarker
and then you were then able to say that
this is the architecture that lights up
when pain is yeah what happens and I and
then there's another complementary
signature that goes with it that is
about that really is designed to track
when modulation of pain is happening so
it captures when people are regulating
their pain experience in some way or
another
using the independent of what they're
actually perceiving what's actually
coming in in a sensory way right so in
this case it was like heat like a little
hot plate that there that's against
their skin right so we can track the the
first marker tracks very closely with
what's on someone's skin and then the
second one tracks really well with
what's independent of that so even given
the same temperature in my skin
everything being the same in the
environment my paint experience is
different and why right because I had
some different expectations or because I
was regulating it intentionally things
like that so I looked at both of these
markers together and I looked at
mindfulness based stress reduction and I
looked at a the control intervention and
what I was looking for were differences
in responses between the two
interventions as well as differences in
the response you know in people's
self-reported responses so how much do
their the brain responses that we see
track with the behavioral responses and
do they tell us anything different they
tell us a little bit about the
mechanisms involved in mindfulness
training as
they relate to paint particularly which
is one important area where mindfulness
based interventions have been used for a
long time going back like 30 years so
all the way to John kabat-zinn who
developed it MBSR and in the 1980s the
very first thing he used it for it was
people who had chronic health conditions
who or severe health conditions and were
coping with a lot of pain so let's go to
press we have so much more to Stowell oh
yeah you're right yeah yeah yeah and
thanks yeah cuz I'd go into so much
detail so yeah so so so bring that to
the president so I've been really
interested in the mechanisms and also we
have this big world of different
treatments so another question you can
ask is what treatments work for who so
an or you can ask how do we get the
right treatment to the right person at
the right time Yeah right so nowadays
nowadays we have we have mindfulness
based interventions we have like
psychotherapy you know I do cognitive
behavioral therapy as well
we have psychopharmaceuticals and as
we're as we're interested in talking
about you even have now this new world
of we have like new novel
pharmaceuticals whatever you know there
are a lot of different terms around like
a psychedelic psychotherapy I kept maps
absolutely right doing really
interesting work that's getting a lot of
attention and there's ketamine there's
another substance that's being used in
treatment of depression now and they're
also now I didn't hear about the
ketamine oh yeah I mean depression yeah
MDMA pts yeah about a third of people
who have treatment resistant depression
respond very strongly to ketamine it's a
temporary effect unless about three
weeks but it's very powerful so
essentially you have a lot of ketamine
clinics opening up all around the
country now and a lot of research on
ketamine
the youth academy and the mechanism
right right there's a real question
again it is it seems to really work very
powerfully but we're not quite sure how
and I'm talking about mindfulness base
and that's kind of behavioral therapy
and them so many and then we have a
class of treatments that work by
stimulating the brain directly so we
have Jan's cranial magnetic stimulation
right so you use a magnetic field to
actually induce some neural activity and
specific parts of your brain and
targeted ways and you have a deep brain
stimulation very fruitful it's results
have been very fruitful yeah so you need
better understanding we have now all of
these different treatments and the thing
is like most of them work but none of
them work a hundred percent of the time
a hundred percent of the way that's
right that's been like a big sticking
point in mental health and psychiatry
both for a long time is has been like
these treatments that are like pretty
effective you know a lot of them they do
better than placebo at least to some
extent but they they still leave a lot
you know they still leave a lot to be
desired so one of the one of the ways to
maybe move forward here is to really get
a better understanding of the brain and
of how these treatments are working in
the brain so then we can actually target
individual processes with individual
treatments matching people to treatments
Reyes like with with psychedelic
assisted psychotherapy that is not
necessarily going to be the right fit
for everybody at all times and it's a
pretty powerful experience and so it's
something you want to be thoughtful
about how and when you recommend it
right when in my clinical work I do a
lot of treatment planning right or care
coordination here right now those are
the things that we think about nowadays
like that graphically had it before
you're literally writing a prescription
for mindfulness right no cool
that's basically it yeah and in fact we
don't want to just write one
prescription we want to put together a
whole plan yeah you know like that
graphic we had it before that had all
those different pieces on and now they
have all this yes yes that wearables
yeah we only have more easily yeah yes
oh we have so much more data so so
here's what I do clinically right we can
we can flip back to the lab in a second
right what we're doing is we're trying
to put together a comprehensive
treatment plan where we
our thinking about what's your
environment like what's your physical
health like are there relaxation
practices you can be doing you know
spiritually
what's your nutrition sleep so this is
completely look at how many categories
you have to pull yeah asking yeah about
in order to make this care plan let's
get to know them like you're their best
friend so yeah yeah exactly so we really
it really involves getting to know
people in detail and it involved having
a great team working in an
interdisciplinary way so it used to be
that mental health psychology
psychotherapy was very siloed like
psychotherapists would work like out of
their living room right and and they
would they might never talk to it you
have an octave like a nutritionist right
when I go yeah when I go into the clinic
so I work in yeah we have nutritionists
nurses psychiatrists like those
psychologists social workers who do will
you know home look like if you don't
have housing very Bay Area issue yeah
you know we know that you you or not
your mental health is never going to be
good unless you have stable housing you
like people who cannot you don't have a
roof over their head and don't have
safety shelter from the elements or if
they have a substance use problem the
chances of them being able to stay sober
are almost nil right but as soon as they
have a roof over their head that totally
changes the games so we can't treat
mental health without social workers
right we need all of these pieces
together so we're taking this much more
integrated piece and looking like all
the tools we have in our arsenal right
can you be running can you be getting
exercise can you be eating better can
you be sleeping better and then also
right do we need to be thinking you know
what kind of medications might help for
you what kind of psychotherapy might
help you are there practices you can do
to train your mind like mindfulness
meditation or like doing yoga and can we
put this together into a step-by-step
plan that all your providers are going
to be working on so that you can
cultivate the optimal well-being for
yourself and this is currently what
you're doing as a postdoc at Stan's
yes so this is like then the clinical
side of what I do yeah this is this is
how I work and it's mostly with the
so yeah in yeah like right now the
clinical work that I do is through the
VA hospital at one of the VA hospitals
in the Bay Area yeah and so the a lot of
what you're seeing right now is the
emotional states the mental health and
well-being of veterans is it needs
attention and the attention can be like
you said so interdisciplinary with the
different teams of people that are
coordinating getting to know them and
then and then again you have writing
this rare plan yeah and so this is
happening how many people do you see
then does like your team your intra
square team
how many people does it work with let's
say every couple of days every month or
how so I can tell you this morning I
went to like the the team report and we
had about I don't know between 15 and 20
people around the table just checking in
on all of the patients that we're
working in with in common across all
these disciplines 7 16 20 people with
yeah t I'm on my team just for that one
clinic and through one clinic and then
the clinic sees how many it would vary I
mean so this is so in this particular
clinic it's like we're doing more
intensive treatment so it might be like
maybe at a time like 40 or 50 patients
but we're you know we're tracking all
events everybody kind of has a care
coordinator so I would be like the
coordinator of care for one person and I
my job is to really have this 360-degree
picture for them for them yeah and you
have like one or a couple of those right
now that you're watching over exactly is
that interesting interesting yeah and
then there's like a strict privacy with
each person's life that you then keep
people that that work in
making these care plans keep a very
strict privacy
oh yeah take privacy very very seriously
confidentiality right absolutely like
that it's that it's like the kind of the
starting point of everything when you're
in a medical setting yeah yeah yeah this
is a privacy ticularly with with
anything to do with mental health
particularly mental yeah yeah yep
interesting
now look thank you Ron this good that's
good I wanted to make sure to get to
prepare to dock yeah wow the spaceships
are flying yeah I thought I'd won the
you know the daily bonus the Daily
Double Joe and the Daily Double is yeah
mindfulness meaning Martin right
mindfulness for 500 whatever fruit loops
I just won it Ron Fogg yes we're and we
may be might be sailing into technology
mention that that the number one
downloaded app that the VA puts the VA
develops on their own apps thing and
number one app on the VA is called
mindfulness coach mindfulness coach yeah
yeah and that's kind of like the insight
timer the column or headspace it's a
whole bunch of tools for yeah practicing
mindfulness meditation loss yeah yeah so
it's like yeah headspace is a really
good one that I also recommend to people
yeah mmm-hmm okay let's do this there's
a lot to talk about with what we kind of
talked about a couple weeks yet two
weeks ago or so yeah all right so what's
going on with the current state of the
way that we use technology and our
behavior with it because from the
perspective of someone that is literally
studying neuroscience of mental health
and well-being
like what's going on and how the hell do
we figure this today and and someone
who's totally struggling with my own so
yeah the way I see this is essentially
that we've got something new in our
society and our culture that we haven't
figured out how to form a healthy
relationship with partly because the
thing itself is kind of social movement
argot right now right
smartphones themselves or just changing
all the time and what they do is
changing but but even even that just the
whole thing is so brand-new and if you
look back in history you know anytime
there is a new technology introduced it
created a huge amount of social change
and social disruption and some you know
often people are excited about it
because they of the things they can't
anticipate that are really good right
but then there's always unanticipated
consequences to like if you look at the
introduction of the car it made it
possible for us to all move out to the
suburbs we right and then we thought
okay now we're gonna it's gonna be
paradise right it turns out not that
didn't quite work out the way we thought
right now all of a sudden we're all
isolated from each other in our you know
five hundred square foot house yeah
right we never see each other we don't
need and instead we're spending an hour
a day in the car and we're not getting
we're not walking anymore and we're
getting out of shape and yeah all kinds
you know and so all of a sudden there's
this whole new class of problems that
nobody I don't think anticipated when
they when you know this was all first
happening so late and it takes society a
few decades to really even catch up with
what was happening put a name to it and
then start to try to figure out and then
all of a sudden you see fitness clubs
everywhere right now that we drive
everywhere we got to have a gym look at
it I love Joe's perspective on on the
evolution of humanity he's like humans
go like paradise paradise paradise and
then we get there and we're like [ __ ]
all these problems we made and then yeah
and then you'd like go back and like
after like backtrack and try to fix
things yeah yeah absolutely and so it's
just it looks the way it looks to me is
like we're going through the exact same
thing smartphones right now we're I mean
my smartphone has been life-changing for
me in positive ways right like I'm I'm a
can be an absent minded person like
being able to have my calendar on my
phone in my pocket all the time is like
an tasks amazing right and things like
that are so great my mom on video
whatever yeah yeah absolutely right yeah
like when you when you have family
around right
the potential to connect people is so
great yeah but then but then
all these things we haven't anticipated
are happening and particularly the big
thing that you know that where
everyone's really noticing now is just
the effect on our attention yeah and
that's because it's such a device that's
so well optimized to capture our
attention and there's so much on there
and then of course as we've talked about
to you like the plans the the world of
technology right has really being able
to kind of get a hint a hold on human
psychology right and really optimize
these apps to tune into it so so as we
talked about or this metaphor it's just
like alcohol right also you know to a
great extent like most of us in our
daily lives are able to walk through a
world where alcohol is on sale at every
corner is on offer at every restaurant
right and and there are people who do
have problems with this and I don't want
to minimize that at all it's like it is
a real issue right but actually to a
great extent most of us are actually
able to go through our life without just
you know sitting down in the corner and
binge drinking
over 90 percent yeah right and and then
the question is why are we able to do
that so one of the reasons it's the
opposite with smart phones over ninety
percent of us are right right and so so
when you look at and and if you look at
societies that didn't have alcohol
historically when I was introduced
they were huge problems because what did
they not have so they didn't have a good
understanding of familiarity of it and
they didn't have good social norms right
to help their idea in terms of how and
when you engage with whatever that's
potentially problematic thing is who's
shouting from the rooftops today turn
all your notifications off focus on your
creative endeavoring right yeah yeah
exactly yeah right and so what you see
is already perhaps you know very quickly
people are immediately starting to think
of okay how what are the ways that we
can actually manage this better reclaim
our mugs and there is a systemic piece
to it too right so like to take another
you know with alcohol or you know
to take like cigarettes is another
example but you know alcohols may be
better because it's one that we a lot of
us do want to enjoy right and we do want
to be able to enjoy a nice glass of wine
I have it happen place in our lives
yeah so what does it take to be able to
create that situation you know we do
regulate the marketing advertising of
alcohol right we regulate where and when
it can be solved sold right like there
has to be systematic restaurants or
planes anymore yeah can't sell alcohol
to under 21 but you can't market
cigarettes to children you can't market
alcohol to children right same thing
happening marijuana no right oh yeah you
know about that's what's for I'm not
like a war on drugs person but the
research on the effect of cannabis on
adolescent brain development is actually
like pretty alarming when you read it
like it really is something about I
turned out fine they don't know same
thing with the alcohol on the yeah yeah
turns out our brains are not Germans
there's a young yeah yeah they're still
developing into our mid-20s and they're
they're very they're sensitive to a lot
of things at those times so it's it's
you know it's worth keeping in mind I
would be interesting to see what the
effects of LSD or psilocybin or DMT are
on maybe 18 21 year olds and how that
potentially gets into you know I
certainly thank you for yeah for another
time for from the kind of work I do I
mean the absolute first imperative is to
be doing no harm right we do not be
putting people at risk and should never
be encouraging people to put themselves
at risk so that's that's where I you
know that's where I come from in this
conversation so so the question is yeah
how do we develop a similarly healthy
relationship with phones need to be
there needs to be institutional action
there needs to be action at level think
so
yeah absolutely please teach us what
your solutions from an institutional
level would be well I'm not an area that
I'm like yeah when we were talking last
you know on the panel I mean
the really the the thing I think that
might make the most sense is to really
think of these things in the same ways
we would think of any you know for
mental health the same way we think of
how a product affects your physical
health if if we think that like a food
or drink or substance might be affecting
people's health we want to do the
research we want to figure out if that's
really the case and then if it is the
case that we need to put in place
policies that that acknowledge that and
that if possible change the product to
you know to make it a healthier product
or if not we put you know we kind of
make sure that we're we're not drawing
people into unhealthy relationships with
it we're putting you know putting enough
checks that people don't get into you
know that we're not yeah that was let's
see if I can get this right simple so it
would be then we go and do the research
starting immediately as much as possible
on what the mental health and well-being
effects are right now of being addicted
to social media and then what we do
after that is we obviously figure out
that there are some negative effects of
our behaviors and technology and then we
say things like okay Instagram you if
someone's browsing through the newsfeed
for three or five minutes straight you
are now you have to forcibly in your
code have to send them a notification
that says do you want to continue
browsing your newsfeed or would you like
to take a break mm-hmm something like
that
yeah and and there are Pete and again
there are people who are working you
know doing lots and lots of work on all
of the strategies there is Mac stossel
these are the center free Maine tech
civility all these and yeah we're very
grateful for them huge shout out to the
ethical tech and design absolutely teams
yeah so the idea being basically you
know if you're presuming something say
their business plans which is the hard
thing it's a well yeah so that's this is
where it's important right so if you
think about I like to you know look at
Philip Mars as a company look at where
they are now
the it's not in your long-term best
interest as a company to be creating a
product that is that damages the health
of your customers right people are gonna
realize that they're going to want to
get away from the product and ultimately
also you're gonna be maybe liable right
there's all kinds of downsides to it so
I actually would argue it into that
that's so agile and and that didn't
happen on you know they didn't just
change that on their own way it took a
lot of public huge public policy effort
hundreds of millions of people will be
transitioning away from using social
media because they themselves will
discover the unhealthy relations are
happening right yeah everybody who talks
about Facebook is talking about yeah you
know I don't really want to be on there
but I I feel like I have to right is
that what you want to be as a product no
like I feel like a pretty sure
Facebook's bad for me but I haven't
figured out how to quit yet damn that
sounds exactly like smoking yeah yeah
you're right right Wow
so yeah that's very that what kind of a
horrible you better transition quick as
a social media company if you want to
you should a social media company could
be at the it could be the biggest they
could have the biggest impact on
civilization if they themselves were to
change their platform away from that and
they could they could be greatly praised
in many ways right so for the people
inside the tech that's the carrot right
and then from the people who are you
know as as citizens right what we can do
is keep the pressure on yeah through
policy you know through in particular
right requiring that the research be
done like if you're if you're gonna be
done if you're gonna do if you're gonna
develop a product at this kind of scale
right where you have millions or
hundreds of millions or a billion users
then then you really should be doing
research you need to be doing research
and making the results public or
somebody should be doing research maybe
even outside your company right the same
way we don't bring drugs on the market
without some without some confidence
that they're safe or we don't bring
medical devices on the market right yeah
that's right and let you know right
there's either a presumption of safety
or there's a presumption that there's
some risk and
we think there's a risk maybe we should
be requiring some kind of research and
requiring the product be designed so
that if it mitigates the impacts that it
finds the research now do you think
taxpayers should be paying for the
research or do you think the company
should be paid for the research so
that's an interesting point and I don't
know that I would have I'm not maybe the
person to answer that question
because they're their trade up either
way right so you either have to have the
funding if they or if they pay for it
then there's the potential conflict of
interest but in terms of pharmaceutical
research the ways this tends to work is
it is the drug companies that do pay for
the research with a lot of scrutiny and
oversight exactly and that doesn't solve
every process all of your problems but
it does it does to some extent work
right to a certain party that's not
involved whatsoever has no monetary ties
whatsoever it creates some
accountability yes so you have
independent that the research is done
often externally yeah and then you have
oversight from the FDA oversight from
NIH and so on so there's still so much
to talk about I feel like you know we've
only scratched the surface with mental
health and well-being and what you know
what you're working on and also what
society's going through right now with
this transition like you said you're you
know eight years that you went through
and boom all of a sudden you're done
with your PhD and there's a hole like
the younger the people that are only
starting are now going through a
completely different technology
landscape and how is that is affecting
mental health and well-being it's just
and how we can actually use it as you
were indicating as a tool for good as
well just couple just quick questions on
the on the way out I like to ask these
questions on the show do you think we're
alone in the cosmos
it's really you know I have to say I'm
I'm I had can't I can't imagine that the
entire observable universe we're alone
no I don't think we are yeah and what do
you think is out there then
who knows yeah yeah little big
imagination though yeah I think that we
definitely have a lot of growing up to
do here on earth we have a water before
we go off trying to find it I think that
that's my that's I used to be really
excited about you know the
extraterrestrials and now I'm kind of
like better get our acting I just mind
your business and not be a good boy if
get our house in order first and then go
you know and then and then go off on
vacation we were we were talking about
it right before we started I'm surprised
that we didn't come up in conversation
but I was like you know if we ascribed
an age to civilization in terms of
maturity you know maybe we would get 10
years old or so and Joe is like you're
less than a year old yeah yeah we're
like the flailing infant stage wailing
infant stage yeah yeah how about do you
think we're in a simulation no I don't
think so you think this is base reality
I think that that idea is is really
biased by the time the place we live and
we just invented the ability to like
simulate computers and we all want
matrix this right so like that's where
my mind goes immediately just like when
people are just invented clocks and
watches they thought the universe was
clockwork oh that was also something
that we got biased towards huh
yeah watches and clocks and then we
thought everything was like
deterministic yeah exactly right
interesting because that was like the
dominant metaphor the motion technology
it was the zeitgeist of the age yeah
that's so interesting so we have a we
have a recency bias towards simulation
very well because we just came up with
these devices that are meant magnificent
at running simulations yeah interesting
interesting
KooKoo I like that that's first time
we've heard that recency bias towards
the towards it and then last question is
what he thinks the most beautiful thing
in the world
Wow
I think the most beautiful thing in the
world is actually any moment when you
are fully present and fully accepting
and fully and I mean I want to say at
peace it's kind of cliched but but what
I really mean is that you're not trying
to change anything in that moment you're
just completely you're completely there
with this
what do you feel when you feel that
I felt a most beautiful thing in the
world ooh yeah that's so good
that's so well said
some we really urge everyone to do their
best to do what
Jojo said as often as possible that was
that was so lost that's the heart of
mindfulness training yeah yeah so yeah
yeah beautiful episode beautiful
conversations I feel so blessed that we
are friends ending sequence music
commencing now there we go
thank you thank you so much for coming
out so Jeff yes such a pleasure nice fun
yeah we I really appreciate you and what
you care about what you're building so
keep it up keep up the good work we have
lots of cool people to connect you to
and connect us to and let's keep
featuring content like this yeah with
smart people like you yeah thank you
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it give us your thoughts in
the comments below we'd love to hear
from you we'd love to hear about how you
yourselves are working on mindfulness on
meditation on ethical tech and your
relationships with it teach us about it
let us know in the comments below also a
huge thank you Ron for producing and
directing much love again everyone go
and manifest your destiny into the world
build the future we love you all we'll
talk to you soon peace
[Music]